[Music]
so good evening time for the Press
preview it's our first look at Sunday's
front pages and tonight we'll be taking
a look at them and the headlines with
the journalist and author Rachel shabby
and the editor of the Jewish Chronicle
Jake Wallace Simon it's great to see you
this Saturday evening we'll chat in a
moment after we've had a look at some of
those papers for you beginning with the
Sunday Mirror we spoke about this bit
earlier in the bulletin it's leading on
that footage that it's obtained of an
apparent Tory lockdown party with the
headline the party gate tapes
the mail on Sunday's headline reads
proof Boris accuser did go to party in
lockdown
the Sun Express says Get a Grip save the
economy reporting conservative MPS have
been told to stop infighting and focus
on inflation while the route over Party
eight rumbles on
while the Observer says just an XMP as
PM Rishi cnx supporters poor scorn on
Boris Johnson
here's your Sunday Telegraph reporting
that secure starman's Chief of Staff Sue
gray could have been suspended or sacked
for a breach of impartiality rules had
she not quit her posting
while the Sunday Times reports on Prince
William's aim to end homelessness in the
UK
and the star features a story of a mum
who claims she now remembers being taken
by aliens 30 years ago
uh don't forget you can scan the QR code
that you see on screen join the program
check out the front pages of tomorrow's
papers while you watch us reviewing them
and to do that Rachel shabby and Jake
Wallace Simons uh good to see you this
Saturday night and lots to talk about in
the Sunday papers Rachel why don't we
start with the the Sunday Mirror it is
quite exclusive this isn't it they're
saying it's the first proper video of a
party gate party going on lockdown
busting parties that shame the
government now we did know about this
party didn't we and there had been
photographs from it but certainly we
haven't seen footage until now
that's right so there have been
photographs of this party before this is
on the 14th of December 2020 it's a
conservative HQ so this is just before
everybody canceled their Christmas plans
or went into quite a strict lockdown
over the Christmas period
there is something so visceral though
about seeing this in video format
um it is sickening it is absolutely
sickening to watch this revelry at a
time when lockdown was imposed and in
fact there's you can hear someone in the
video
um ask about the fact that it's been
filmed and then say you know as long as
we don't stream that we're like bending
the rules quote so they knew exactly
what they were doing and the thing that
is so maddening about it is the
absolute disdain that it shows for
everybody else in this country who was
trying to do their best and trying to
follow the rules
um of people who weren't seeing their
loved ones including loved ones who they
then had to bury and weren't allowed to
to be with at that horrible time uh
including the disdain for people who
worked on the front lines including
health care and the extraordinary
agonizing dangerous work that they all
did the absolute contempt for people who
were you know just trying to do their
jobs or to just get through what was a
horrendous period and and the nail the
absolute nail that driven through but
the heart of people that makes people
feel so sick and maddened by this is the
fact that you know the people who were
on the front lines and who we should be
thanking for their service to this
country during the pandemic and now on
picket lines fighting for pay that is
just not pulverized by inflation while
the people who completely disregarded
the rules and have us you know such a
disdain for the public are being
rewarded so you know Sean Bailey who was
at this party got rewarded with a
peerage
um Ben Mallett the conservative
campaigner also at this party uh got an
Obe both from Boris Johnson so that's
the bit that really makes it so very
maddening
um and it and it does make you think
about all the people who uh lost loved
ones and went through the most agonizing
circumstances during that period
um only to have their you know
salt rubbed in their wounds uh by this
video today yeah I mean it is
um it is quite something Jake this video
isn't it we know an investigation uh
happened we know that Sean Bailey who
was the conservative London mayoral
candidate fully apologized and and
stepped down but do you think now that
we see the video that the story moves on
at all can anything else happen as a
result of it or is it simply a case of
watching it being shocked by it
and then I guess having to move on
well there could be an implication from
the uh emergence of the video which is
that when the police investigated this
incident uh last time uh the video
wasn't available and they were making
judgments based on a couple of pictures
and as a result they said they didn't
have enough evidence to prove uh a
strong enough criminal case against the
people in the picture and the
implication from the mirror story may be
that the that this video May Give Them
Enough evidence to begin to bring
charges against people who were at the
party it's not made explicit in the
mirror story but certainly the
implication is there but I take a
slightly different view on it from
Rachel I mean of course I'm not
condoning any of this but I don't think
that foremost in those people's minds in
Tori HQ was contempt for the public I
think it was more a sense that the rules
weren't really a weren't really worth
following in their minds and B were too
complicated to understand anyway and I
think that at that time if you think
about what else was going on in
government the telegraph's lockdown
files those leaked messages from Matt
Hancock showed that around that time he
was seeking to uh I think his words were
deploy the new variant in a p in PR
terms to frighten the pants off the
public to soften them up for locking
down over Christmas and what it really
brings home I think is that a lot of
these rules that the government imposed
upon the public were unnecessary were
overly complicated and really
infantilized people and took away their
Liberty to decide for themselves the
level of their vulnerability and what
was the best way to live their lives in
accordance with the threat they
perceived from the virus I mean you know
everybody watching this will have have
memories and and stories of not being
able to sit on park benches or take dogs
for walks or whatever that were a
totally absurd uh Draconian and
authoritarian measures imposed by the
government and often so complicated that
we didn't even know what we weren't
allowed to do and clearly people inside
Downing streets and inside cchq in
London at this party we're going to sit
in the same boat they didn't respect the
rules because you they were over the top
and this was the result although I guess
you know it it is easy with hindsight to
say that isn't it I mean I know at the
time
um many people were suggesting that the
rules were or some of the rules were uh
uh pointless but you know you know we
know a lot more now than we did back
then and partygate is on the front of
the mail as well uh Rachel
um still rumbling on of course but this
is a a different story the male's still
Furious isn't it about the Privileges
committee findings and um they're taking
aim at the what they call Boris
Johnson's Chief party gate Inquisitor
just just explain this story to us
I will explain the story but I also
think it's worth pointing out that you
know the the male I just think that any
any newspaper that puts on its front
page
um in quote marks Witch Hunt over a
privileges committee inquiry should not
be signal boosted by us on on Broadcast
News because it's because it's already
part of a a very sort of dangerous
destabilization of democratic Norms
um and so I actually don't think this
story is worthy of discussion
um what it what it is talking about is
the fact that um one of the one of the
people who was sitting on that
privileges committee
which was selected by the government and
commissioned by the government and had a
government majority on it
um one of those people uh Smyrna Jenkins
he was apparently at a broke broke rules
at a party of his own and so uh The
Daily Mail is calling this an exclusive
and and
further proof of what it considers to be
a stitch up
Jake
well I profoundly disagree I think this
is very very newsworthy indeed
um there certainly were elements of a
Witch Hunt I wouldn't personally go
quite so far as the mail goes but
certainly you know a lot of the people
on the panel of the Privileges committee
including Harriet Harman had gone public
saying that they'd concluded that Boris
had lied before they even began the uh
the inquiry and that isn't isn't fair
and right and impartial and now we find
out that sir Bernard Jenkins who's the
most senior senior Tori on the committee
himself apparently uh broke the lockdown
rules in exactly the same way and yet
had the brass neck to uh to take part in
this inquiry uh scrutinizing Boris
Johnson's behavior and so I think the
whole thing really is a very unedifying
um Carnival of hypocrisy in in all
different directions with people using
the opportunity of the inquiry to settle
scores and to make political to score
political points
um and nobody really comes out of it
looking good or smelling it roses
neither Boris nor the people who were
launching the inquiry against him
yeah so having said that it leads us
very nicely Rachel doesn't it onto the
front of the Sunday Express is it time
to put the Boris Johnson psychodrama
behind us put partygate behind us move
on because we need to focus on a lot of
big issues big problems that the country
is facing
yeah absolutely what I think is really
interesting is that the three newspapers
who are cheerleaders for the government
we've got one of them
um that is very basically a Boris
Johnson fan club and has just um
appointed him as a columnist for
extraordinarily huge sums of money The
Daily Mail so one of them saying oh well
the people who attack him are just as
bad as him and then we've got the
express
say well nothing to see here let's just
move on and then we've got the telegraph
we'll see in a minute with a rehash
story about Sue gray which we'll talk
about in a minute and so this is the
express
um saying we should just get over this
and have the government go back to
talking about the economy I actually do
think that Boris Johnson is now a drain
and a distraction
um from the business of government but I
actually think these entire conservative
government is a distraction from the
business of government because they're
the ones that keep getting caught up in
this drama and this internal incessant
internal fighting uh between the
factions so you know no great surprises
there really yeah Joe what what do you
think the public make of all this what
are the public make of these headlines
day after day about partygate about
Boris Johnson
um do you think there is still
um interest in it interesting what went
on in the past or do you think like the
Sunday Express voters want us to move on
I think really there's a a double
Instinct amongst the par amongst the
public uh on the one hand Boris is
endlessly provocative and fascinating
and controversial and people like
thinking about him and reading about him
and the Tory woes it appeals to a sort
of uh you know tawdry Instinct uh to to
you know people wanting to watch this
sort of slow motion Tory car crash uh
but at the same time
um on a more serious note people are
worried about their standard living and
how far their or how how uh how little
distance their money is now stretching
increasingly as time goes by and with
interest rates coming up next week up to
4.75 percent you know home repossessions
are going up businesses are beginning to
fold and the economic woes are really
being felt hard by people and everybody
I think really above all wants this to
get better and there's a real sense that
the Tories are not focusing fully on the
economy because they're too busy
stabbing each other in the back the
front and the side again and again and
again and then doing it again and so I
think there is really interesting that
as entertaining and sort of Tory is all
this is we do need the government does
need to begin to really focus
exclusively on governing and mend the
broken economy uh front page of the
Sunday Times uh Jake why don't you kick
off this part and there's an exclusive
interview here with uh William where the
Prince of Wales talks about using his
own land for social housing it's all
part of a big Push by him to try and end
homelessness
it's interesting isn't it that uh Prince
William has chosen this particular cause
to focus on right now uh is not a
glamorous or sexy cause it's
homelessness in Britain it's not you
know Elephants or land mines it's it's
people living on the streets in our own
country close to home
um and he's you know he's setting out
his stall to try to end homelessness as
the headline says which is a very
obviously ambitious Target but bringing
it down would help and one of his um
proposals to do so is to set up social
housing on his land the duchy of
Cornwall land to house homeless people
obviously this is a hugely virtuous and
admirable uh cause and proposal from
Prince William and it just contrasts so
starkly with the activities recently of
his brother who is uh you know
um engaged in this battle after battle
in the courts with the media uh who's
shamelessly self-promoting with regard
to podcasts and uh social media and all
the rest of it and above all taking
potshot at his own family in public so I
think the contrast between them is very
very Stark indeed and William is showing
himself to be boring but doing the right
thing and that's really what we need
from our royal family boring but doing
the right thing uh he's also released
that photograph that's on the front of
the Sunday Times uh this evening uh for
Father's Day whatever you think of the
royal family Rachel it is a cute photo
isn't it George 9 Charlotte 8 Louis
um on his shoulders there that photo
taken at Windsor the prince saying uh
Rachel that he wants to particularly
Target hidden youth homelessness that
that phrase sofa surfing comes up a lot
doesn't it
yeah I think that that he's right about
that there is a lot of hidden um youth
homelessness that is is couched uh no
pun in in these terms there is also a
lot of Youth homelessness on the street
so we can see we can see that
um first of all we can see with our own
eyes that homelessness has increased in
the UK and we can also see that that
there are a a terrifying really alarming
um number of young people on the streets
as well
um rough sleepers uh it's it's great uh
that um Prince William wants to raise
awareness of this I think it's very
important that someone like him speaks
about
you know understanding uh the
circumstances in which people
um end up sleeping rough and trying to
destigmatize that but it does make you
think you know he says he wants to end
homelessness well I mean that's great
but it's actually the government's job
so it does make you wonder why the
government isn't doing it yes we need
social housing uh we need the government
to be doing that we need the government
to be committing to that which by the
way would also be a huge jobs creation
program so it does to me
um shine a light rather starkly on on
the government's failure in this
department okay you can read more uh in
the Sunday Times from William let's move
on to the front of the Observer Jake
schools in England are struggling to
recruit English teachers this story
coming of course is uh more strikes are
announced today
yes it's interesting there so I
apparently uh English teachers are
normally the easiest to recruit and it's
normally uh in the other subjects maths
and Sciences that schools experience
difficulties in attracting uh staff but
now even English teachers are difficult
to to find as well I think that really
this speaks about the um the collapse
the denigration of English as a
discipline uh in Britain we've had an
increasing focus on the stem subjects as
they're called maths and Sciences
because there seem to be more
economically worthwhile
um and English and the Arts have been
consistently sidelined as we substitute
our ideals of pursuing knowledge uh for
its own sake for the goodness of of our
nation for a more commercially driven
approach towards education and to me
that's a great great shame and combined
as you say with the uh teacher strikes
which are continuing more coming this
week I think we really are doing a great
disservice to the Next Generation yeah
it's interesting with the strikes um
isn't it Rachel because the unions are
saying it's not just about pay obviously
pay is a big part of it but it's all
about these issues that Jake's just
talked about as well recruitment funding
um that is as important to teachers
today as their payers
of course
um part of the issue with uh uh
recruitment is that is precisely that
it's low pay it's the fact that teachers
are so overworked
um it's pressures of being sort of over
over sort of inspected potentially
um and just having much more admin work
to do leaving less time for teaching
which is what you know vocationally
teachers are driven to do so I don't
think that what Jake is suggesting is
right I think what I'm reading from this
article is that
uh recruitment has become bad or has
been bad for some time amongst in other
uh for areas like math science Etc and
now the Recruitment and the shortages
have become so acute that they're
actually leeching into and bleeding into
and extending outwards into areas where
traditionally there have been fewer
shortages so I think it points to the
scale of the crisis and you've got
people uh from the education Union in
this piece saying they're not using the
term crisis lightly but it also of
course underlines why they are
absolutely right to be striking uh for
therapy and better conditions because if
they don't get paid that is at the very
least in line with inflation then how on
Earth are they going to recruit more
staff